pegi 16
gotham il n'y aura pas d'autres
avertissements abandonner la vie où
j'étais chez nadège vos plus grandes
pales
desta mans et dernières volontés du
défunt de masse wait
dans l'éventualité de mon décès je
déclare par le présent testament légué
tous mes biens matériels à mon fils
bruce wayne bros
je compte sur toi pour faire honneur à
l'héritage de la famille wade en te
consacrant au développement et à la
prospérité de gotham de ses institutions
et de ses citoyens
mon fils soit fort tu es jeune mais
destinés à de grandes choses
profite de toutes les opportunités qui
s'offrent à toi l'utilisent l'est pour
rendre service à cette ville qui nous a
tant donné pour changer la vie de
millions de gens ne cède jamais à la
frivolité ne dilapide pas ta fortune
dans les voitures de sport
les vêtements extravagants et les
nombreux pièges d'un train de vie
destructeur
investi dans gotham
considère ses habitants comme ta famille
veille sur eux et utilisent cet argent
pour les protéger des menaces auxquelles
il pourrait devoir faire face
mon plus grand regret nous sera de ne
pouvoir connaître cet homme formidable
que tu deviendras sans aucun doute
enfin mon fils je compte sur toi pour ne
jamais abandonner cette ville à son sort
nous avons connu des jours sombres et
nul doute que d'autres surviendront les
hommes droits et honnêtes se doivent de
lutter pour gotham quand d'autres
préfèrent fuir
au delà de la mort je t'aimerai toujours
ton père de masse
nous